The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So let's get started.
So I'm going to lecture today,
Professor Zweback's away.
And I just wanted to
say a couple of things,
just in case you
haven't noticed.
We posted the
solutions for P-set 11.
And then also later
in the week, we'll
post the solutions for the
extra problems that came along
with P-set 11, so you
can look at those.
And also, there's two
past exams with solutions
also on the website now.
So you can start
going through those.
And also, there's a
formula sheet there.
And if you've got
suggestions for things
that you think should be
on there that aren't, let
us know and they probably
can be put on there.
So I want to turn
back to what we
were doing at the end of last
lecture, which was talking
about the spin-orbit coupling.
And so this is a contribution
to our Hamiltonian
that looks like
spin of the electron
dotted into the angular
momentum that the electron has
around the proton in
the hydrogen atom.
And so because of
this term we had
to change the complete set
of commuting observables
that we wanted to talk about.
So we have now this
full Hamiltonian
that includes this piece that
has the Se dot L term in it.
We have L squared, we
have the spin squared.
But because of this piece,
Lz, which was previously
one of the quantum numbers we
used to classify things by,
that doesn't commute
with this term, right?
So here we have to
throw that one away.
Similarly, we have
this throw away
the z component of
the electron spin.
That doesn't commute
with this either.
And what we replace
those by is actually
the J squared and
the Z component of J.
So J is the vector sum
of the angular momentum
and the spin of the electron.
And this is very interesting.
This term does
something interesting.
So if we look at--
let me go up here.
If we remember the
hydrogen states
when we don't have
this term, there's
a state that has n
equals 2 and l equals 1.
And you can think of
that as three states.
And then we've got to
tensor that with the spin,
so the spin of the electron
could be spin up or spin down.
So there's a spin a half,
so this is two states.
And so you've got a
total of six states
you're going to talk about.
And now what we have
to do is classify these
according to the quantum
numbers that are actually
preserved by the system.
So we can't use Lz or Sz.
We have to use J squared and Jz.
So we've got a J
equals 3/2 multiplet--
and that's four states--
plus a J equals 1/2.
And you can see the number
of states works out.
We've got 3 times 2
is equal to 4 plus 2.
And so this L dot S term takes
these original six states,
which without this
interaction degenerate,
and it splits them
into the four states
up here, and then
two states down here.
The J equals 1/2, J equals 3/2.
And we also worked
out the splittings.
If I do this, this is
plus h bar squared over 2.
And this is minus h bar squared.
So this gives you a splitting.
Now this is not the only thing
that happens in hydrogen,
because you probably all
know that the proton itself
has spin.
The proton has a spin
1/2 particle, just
like the electron.
It's even more
complicated because it's
a composite object.
But that leads to additional
splittings in hydrogen.
And so these ones,
this one here is
called the defined structure.
Or we can also talk about
the type hyperfine structure.
So this is going to be a small
effect on top of this one.
So we have the proton
that's spin 1/2,
we have the electron
spin a half,
and then we have the relative
orbital angular momentum.
And so the total
angular momentum,
which is J, which is going to
be the sum of L plus the spin
of the electron plus the spin of
the proton, this is conserved.
And the thing we were
talking about here
is actually not conserved.
So once you worry about
the spin of the proton
you've got to look at the
total angular momentum.
And that's what
will be conserved.
And so our complete set
of commuting observables
is going to be a four
Hamiltonian, which we'll get to
in a moment, L squared
the spin squareds
of the proton and the
electron, and then J squared,
and finally Jz is
the things that we're
going to end up
classifying states by.
So we originally
thought about these two
here, and did a
coupling between those.
It's pretty natural to
assume that there maybe
couplings between the
angular momentum and the spin
of the proton, which there are.
But also there's going to be
a coupling between the spins
of the electron and the proton.
And that's the one we're going
to talk about at the moment.
The other one is there but we
won't go over it in any detail.
So the proton and the electron
both spin 1/2 particles,
and they both have
magnetic dipole moments,
which are proportional
to their spin.
And so it's really a coupling
between these moments that
tells us what the effect of
this interaction is going to be.
So we have the mu
of the electron
is equal to e over
me-- minus me--
times the spin of the electron.
And mu of the proton is,
let me just write it as gp.
And gp happens to have
the value of about 5.6.
And this is actually
kind of interesting.
So if you look at
the formula up here,
really I could have written this
as a g over 2, with g being 2.
So for the electron, the g
factor is very close to 2.
This is because the
electron is essentially
a fundamental particle,
with no substructure.
But the proton, which is
made up of quarks and gluons
flying around inside some
region, has a lot of structure.
And so this is really
indicative of it
being a composite particle.
Because a fundamental
spin 1/2 particle
should have this g being 2.
So we've got these
two dipole moments.
And one way to
think about this is
you've got this
dipole of the proton.
We're going to think
about the proton having
a little dipole charge--
sorry, dipole magnetic moment--
and this produces
a magnetic field.
And the electron is sitting
in that magnetic field.
And its spin can
couple to the field.
So we're going to
have a Hamiltonian,
a hyperfine
Hamiltonian, that looks
like minus mu of
the electron dotted
into a magnetic field produced
by the proton, which is going
to depend on r, on
where the electron is.
And you can simplify
this as just
e over m spin of
the electron dotted
into this B of the proton.
So we need to know what
this dipole field is.
And for that you really have
to go back to electromagnetism.
And you've probably
seen this before.
But let me just write it down,
and we won't derive it here.
But let's go down here.
This has a kind of
complicated form.
So there's this piece,
and then there's
another piece that looks like
8 pi over 3c squared mu p times
the delta function
at the origin.
And so you think
about the dipole field
arising from a spinning
charge distribution here.
So we've got a magnetic
dipole moment pointing up.
This produces a field
like this, a dipole type
field going this way.
So this is our B.
And then inside here,
you should really
think of taking the limit as
this thing goes to 0 size.
And so in order to get the
right field in the middle,
you need to have this term here.
And so if you want to
see this being derived
you can look in Griffiths.
That does the
derivation of this.
But we will skip that.
So we've got the field.
And now we can put it
into our Hamiltonian.
So it's mu e.
So I could replace my
mu's with the spins.
So I get some
factor out the front
that looks like ge squared
over 2 Me Mp c squared.
And then I get 1
over r cubed plus--
So just plugging those in we
get this Hamiltonian here.
And let me just
simplify a little bit.
Let's just call this thing q.
And so this Hamiltonian
is going to be given by q.
And I can write it as the i-th
component of the electron spin,
the j-th component
of the proton spin,
dotted into r hat i hat
j minus-- So just taking
the common factors of the
spins components out the front.
So if we've got
this, we want to ask
what it's going to do to
the energy of the ground
state of hydrogen.
So we're going to take
matrix elements of this
between the hydrogen
wave functions.
So does anyone have
questions so far?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you use
r as a [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Right right.
So these are unit vectors
in the r direction.
And this r is the length
of the vector, r vector.
The usual thing.
So what we're going
to try and evaluate
is the expectation value.
So we're going to do this.
Because going back to the
start of last lecture,
this is going to be
a small correction.
And so we can work out its
contribution to the energy
by using the original
wave functions,
but just calculating
its matrix elements.
So we're going to
calculate-- and let me just
give this a name.
This can be--
So this is q, and
the ground state
has no angular dependents.
So in fact, for
the ground state,
I can just write this is
a function of r squared.
For overtly excited
states I can't do that.
But for the ground
state that works.
And then we have, so we've
got the wave function.
And then in between them we have
to put this stuff over here.
So let's put the there.
So one of these terms is
very easy to evaluate.
With this [INAUDIBLE]
function I just
get the wave function
at the origin.
And the second term
is actually also
relatively easy to evaluate.
Who can tell me what this
integral over all three
directions of just
one direction?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: 0.
And you can argue that by just
asking, well what can it be?
It's got to carry an
index, because there's
an index on this
side of the equation.
And there's no other vectors
around in this problem.
So the only thing
it can be is 0.
So if I do integral d3r of
ri rj, what can that be?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: 1?
No.
So it's got two indices.
So the thing on this
side of the equation
also has to have two indices.
AUDIENCE: Delta ij?
PROFESSOR: Delta ij, very good.
So the only thing that can
carry two indices is delta ij.
And then there might
be some number here.
And it actually
turns out that you
can do an even more
complicated integral.
We can look at integral d3r
of ri rj sum f of r squared.
And that is also
just some number,
which depends on what
f is, times delta ij.
And if you go along these lines
and actually look at this,
the difference between
the integral of this piece
and the integral of this piece
is actually a factor of 1/3.
And so this actually
integrates to 0.
So when I integrate
over this one,
I get something times delta ij.
And that something
is actually 1/3.
And so this term and this
term cancel in the integral.
And so you just get the
delta function contributions.
So you get some number
times Sei S delta ij.
So it becomes Se dotted into Sp.
8 pi over 3.
And then it's psi
100 at the origin.
So this we know, we've already
computed these radial wave
functions, and saw at
the origin this one
is actually 1 over pi
times the Bohr constant.
And if you plug-in what Q is,
and what the Bohr constant is,
you can just find out that
this whole thing ends up
looking like 4/3
this gp and this
we can call delta e hyperfine.
So you end up with
a very simple thing.
And it's just proportional
to the dot product of the two
spins.
So you've seen, essentially, you
saw this term in your homework.
So we just assume that this
thing here came out of nowhere
and was just some
number times Se dot Sp,
and this was a contribution
to your Hamiltonian.
But now we actually know
where that comes from.
And interestingly, this thing
here, this whole thing, it's
still an operator because
it's got these spins in it.
And that's-- put a star next
to that because it's important.
So now we need to ask, well what
are the real states of hydrogen
so they're where
we've got two spins?
The spin of the proton,
they could be aligned,
or they could be anti-aligned.
Oh, sorry.
We have a question up there.
AUDIENCE: Is that
np over np, or mu u?
PROFESSOR: No, me, mass.
Mass of the electron
over mass of the proton.
So you have to remember
that the spins of the proton
and the electron to can parallel
or they can be anti-parallel.
Or they can be both down.
And so we have to go
back and work out-- we
have to realize that
because of these terms
the z components of those spins
are not good quantum numbers.
The only z component
that appears in our list
is Jz, so the total z
component of angular momentum.
So we need to go back and
do what you-- you probably
have done this to the P-set.
But let's just do
it very quickly.
We'll take those
two spin 1/2 things
and so let's make this
J1 and this is J2.
And we're going to have J.
So if I've got these two spins
I can make various things.
I can write down-- And
if I've done this than
I should also write that the
m, the m quantum number that
goes with the J
quantum number is
going to be equal to m1 plus m2.
So this state here, because both
of the spins are pointing up,
this is an m equals 1 state.
And then we can also have
something like 1/2, 1/2.
You could have these two states.
So they both have m equals 0.
And then there's an m equals
minus 1, which is 1/2 this guy.
So since this has m
equals 1, and 1/2 cross
1/2 is going to give us a
spin 0 multiplet and a spin 1
multiplet, because
it's got m equals 1,
this has to be J
equals 1 as well.
And this one has
to be J equals 1.
But the two states
in the middle,
we don't know what those are.
There's going to
be a J equals 1,
m equals 0 state,
which is going to be
some linear combination
of these two.
So let's just go over here.
We don't need any of this.
And we need to work out what
the linear combination is.
So something to
remember is this.
The J plus or minus acting on
Jm is this funny square root
thing.
So these are the raising
and lowering operators.
They take us from one state
to the one with a different m
value.
And so we can use
that to start with.
We could basically take
J minus on our state.
And according to
this formula, this
will give us the square root
of 1 times 2 minus m is 1.
And this should be 0, right?
I think I've got this
sign up the wrong way.
I think this is minus plus.
No, sorry, that's right.
It should be-- I'm
doing the J minus
so I have 1 times 1 minus--
yeah, right, so it's this.
So this is square root
2 times Jm minus 1.
But we also know that J minus
a is equal to J1 minus plus J2
minus because J is just the
vector sum of the two J's.
So we can ask what J
minus on the state is.
But this state we can write in
terms of the tensor product.
So this is equal to J1 minus 1.
If we use this formula
for lowering something
with spin 1/2 we get 1/2 times
3/2 minus 1/2 times minus 1/2,
which is actually 1
under that square root.
And so this actually equals
1/2 minus 1/2 tensor 1/2, 1/2.
So these two things are equal.
And so that tells us, in
fact, that the 1, 0 state,
which is what's over
here-- oh, sorry.
Oh, why did I do that?
This should be J
equals 1 and M equals
what it was, minus 1, this.
So the 1, 0 state, if we
bring that 1 over root 2
on the other side
is this combination.
So it's one linear combination
of those two pieces.
We also want the other one.
So we've got three
of our states.
The fourth state
is then, of course,
the other linear combination
of the two states over there.
And so that's going to be our
J equals 0, M equals 0 state.
So this state is going to be
orthogonal to the one we've
just written here.
And so this is pretty
easy to work out.
Since there's only
two terms, all we
do is change the
sign of one of them
and it becomes orthogonal,
because these states here
are normalized.
So this becomes
1/2, 1/2 tensor--
let me just write it
in the same way that--
1/2 minus 1/2 minus--
And so our four states, so
we can condense our notation
so we can say that this state
we can just label as this.
And we can just label
as a down arrow.
And then something like we can
label as just up down, just
to make everything compact.
You just have to remember
that this is referring
to the first spin,
this is always
referring to the second spin.
And so then we can
write our multiplets.
J equals 1 has three states.
It has up, up.
It has up, down plus down, up.
And it has down, down.
So those are our three
states that have J equals 1.
And then we have
J equals 0, which
just has 1 over square root
2 up, down minus down, up.
And so the two spins
in our hydrogen
atom, the spin of the
proton and the electron,
can combine to be a J equals
1 or a J equals 0 system.
And since we're talking about
the ground state of hydrogen,
it has 0 angular momentum.
And so I'm really just
talking about J total, here.
So if we now have this
Hamiltonian, which is still
an operator in
spin-- we've dealt
with the spacial dependence
of the wave functions,
but it's still an
operator in spin--
we can now evaluate this.
So we can take its expectation
value in either the J equals 1
multiplet or the J
equals 0 multiplet.
So let's just
write it out again.
So we have h hyperfine 1, 0, 0.
This is equal to some delta E
HF spin of the electron dotted
into the spin of the proton.
We can rewrite this using
something we did last time.
We can write this as J
squared minus Se squared
minus Sp squared, with
the 1/2 out the front.
So here, because l equals 0
because we're in the ground
state, then J equals Se plus Sp.
And so J squared
is going to give us
Se squared, Sp squared,
and then the dot product.
So great.
So what is this, the spin
squared of the electron?
What's the eigenvalue
of J squared, always?
J, J plus 1 times h bar squared.
And what is J for the electron?
1/2.
And what about the proton?
AUDIENCE: 1/2 as well.
PROFESSOR: 1/2.
So we've got 1/2 times
1/2 plus 1, so 3/2.
So this gives us minus 3/4.
This gives us minus 3/4.
So this just looks
like delta e HF
over 2 J squared minus
3/2 h bar squared.
OK?
Anyone lost doing that?
Or is that OK?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: So, when you
define delta e [INAUDIBLE]
over there, that exudes energy?
PROFESSOR: Oh, you're right.
You're very right.
I've messed up.
I've--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Let me see.
Yeah, really I have
an h bar squared here.
I think I should have had an h
bar squared over there as well.
Yeah.
That should be over
h bar squared here.
Thank you.
OK so--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: When does
it get [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That was
just in the algebra
going from this expression,
writing it in terms of alpha,
things like that.
So it's just some algebra.
OK, anything else?
No?
Good.
OK so now we can easily
evaluate these things.
We can now take J
equals 1 and some M--
and this is for M equals all
three states here-- and just
evaluate this.
And all that means is
we have this J squared
operator acting on
this state here.
And this gives us h bar
squared 1 times 1 plus 1,
or 2h bar squared.
So this will give us
delta e hyperfine over 2.
And then we've got, let's
pull the-- sorry there's still
and h bar squared here,
and an h bar squared there.
But now we can evaluate.
The h bar squared
here cancels that one,
and we get a 1 times
a 1 plus 1 minus 3/2.
And that's just one
quarter, which is--
And similarly we can take
the J equals 0 state,
and this one gives us
delta e hyperfine over 2.
And then it's 0
time 1 minus 3/2.
And so that equals
minus 3/4 EHF.
So what we're
doing is evaluating
these in these
particular J states.
And now we end up with
something that's just a number.
It's no longer an operator.
It's an energy that
we can measure.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So, this
expectation value
h hyperfine 1, 0, 0,
is still an operator.
Is that because we only
took the expectation value
over the angular [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: We took over
the spacial wave function.
We did the r integral, right?
But we didn't--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right, right.
Yeah.
So this is actually a
really important system.
So let's just draw the
energy level diagram here.
And here we have four states.
We have the spin
1/2 times spin 1/2.
So 2 times 2 states.
So we get a triplet
and a singlet.
And what this hyperfine
splitting does
is take those four states and
split the triplet up here,
and split the singlet down here.
And this gap we
can see is-- oops,
so this should be a delta HF.
So this gap is delta E HF.
So it's 1/4 and minus 3/4.
And if you plug
numbers in, delta E HF,
this actually ends up being
5.9 times 10 to the minus 6
electron volts, which
is a pretty small scale.
So you should be comparing
that to the binding energy
of the ground state of hydrogen
of 13.6 electron volts.
So this is a very small effect.
And you can really think
about the relative size.
So the Bohr energy, so
that 13.6, formally this
goes like, alpha squared
times Me c squared.
Then last time we talked about
the S coupling, so the spin
orbit, or fine structure.
And so this one we found went
like alpha to the fourth Me C
squared.
So smaller than
the binding energy
by a factor of 1 over 137
squared, or about 20,000.
And then this one
that we're talking
about here, the hyperfine,
this, if you look over here,
this is going like
alpha to the fourth Me C
squared times an additional
factor of Me over Mp.
And the mass of the proton
is about 2,000 times
the mass of the electron.
And so this again
is-- oh, sorry.
This is alpha to the fourth.
So this is suppressed by
about another factor of 2,000.
You can go further.
There are further
corrections to this
in something called
the Lamb shift, which
we won't say
anything else about.
This goes like alpha to
the fifth Me C squared.
And there's a whole host of
higher order corrections.
People actually calculate
these energy levels
to very high precision.
But we won't do any more.
So this transition
here is actually
astrophysically
extremely important.
So if we think about something
sitting in the state here,
it can decay down to the ground
state by emitting a photon.
So we can decay from J equals
1 to J equals 0 by a photon.
And that photon will
have a wavelength
that corresponds exactly
to this energy difference.
And so that wavelength
is going to be,
we can write it as c
over the frequency,
or hc-- oh, hc not h bar c--
hc over this delta e hyperfine.
If you plug numbers
into this you
find out that this is
approximately 21.1 centimeters.
And the frequency
is 1,420 megahertz.
And so right in
the middle-- well,
at the end-- of the
FM band in radio.
So theses are radio waves.
So the size of this wavelength
is firstly important
because it's large compared
to the size of dust
in the universe.
So dust is little stuff.
So this is essentially
goes straight through dust.
So these photons will go
straight through dust.
The other important thing
is that you probably
know that there's a cosmic
microwave background
radiation in the universe,
that's essentially very
close to constant everywhere.
And so we have,
essentially, we have
a temperature of 2.7 Kelvin.
That corresponds to photons
with an energy kT, which
is about 0.2 times 10 to
the minus 3 electron volts.
So milli electron volts.
But if you compare this
number to what we have here,
this cosmic background
microwave radiation
can excite hydrogen
from here up to here.
There's enough energy
for one of those photons
to come along, knock
the hydrogen atom,
and excite it up to here.
And then it will
decay and will emit
this beautiful 21
centimeter line,
which will go
through all the dust.
And so we can actually see the
universe in this 21 centimeter
line.
Even more remarkable is,
we can't calculate this
at the moment, but you
can show that the lifetime
for this transition to happen
is about 10 to the 7 years.
So we can never
measure that in a lab.
But because these
hydrogen atoms can
be wandering around
the universe,
not interacting for that
long, then they can emit.
And so we can see that.
This was first
observed in about 1951,
and is the first
way that we actually
saw that the galaxy
had spiral shaped arms.
So it's pretty important.
And another nice
thing about this
is if you think about
another galaxy--
so let me just draw
another galaxy, a spiral
galaxy somewhere
else, like this.
Let's have us over here looking
at this galaxy from side on.
This galaxy is rotating.
So this one's moving this way,
this one to moving this way.
There's hydrogen over
here and over here.
And so we get these
photons coming over here,
and photons coming
to us from there.
But what's going to be
different about these?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Their
rate shifted, right?
The Doppler shifted.
So this is my 21
centimeter photon.
But they get Doppler shifted.
And so we can measure
the difference
in the frequencies of those.
What does that tell us?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: How fast this
galaxy is spinning, right?
And so one very
interesting thing
you find from that is if
you look at the galaxy
and count how many
stars are in it,
and essentially
work out how massive
that galaxy is, the
speed of rotation
here is actually-- that you
measure from these hydrogen
lines-- is that
it's actually faster
than the escape
velocity of the matter.
And so if all that was there
was the visible matter, then
the thing would just fall apart.
And so this actually
tells you that there's
dark matter that
doesn't interact
with visible light, that's
kind of all over here.
So that's kind of a
pretty interesting thing.
So that, I think, yeah.
So any questions about that?
We're going to move
on to another topic.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: You said
earlier [INAUDIBLE]
it's 10 to the 7 years.
Does that mean it
takes an average of 10
to the 7 years for the cosmic
microwave background energy
to shift back [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, it's
really, if I just
took hydrogen in this state,
and took a sample of it,
that's how long it would
take for half of it
to have gone and made the decay.
So it can happen much faster.
And there's a lot of
it in the universe.
So there's many more
than 10 to the 7 atoms
of hydrogen in the universe.
So we see more than one of
these things every year.
So if you were just
looking at one of them
you would have to
wait a long time.
AUDIENCE: But the thing about
the cosmic microwave background
is to go from [INAUDIBLE] from
0 to 0 up to get [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right so I
mean the energy is large
compared to that.
So it will typically knock you
up into an even higher state.
And then you will
kind of decay down.
But then this last decay
is-- because this lifetime
is very long, the width of this
line is also very, very narrow.
So now let's talk more about
adding angular momenta.
Oh, maybe I should
have left that up.
Too late.
So we're going to do this
in a more general sense.
So we're going to
take J1, some spin
J1 that has states J1, M1,
with M1 equals minus J up to J.
And so we're sort of
talking about something
like the electron in
the hydrogen atom.
And so that's not in any
particular orbital angular
momentum.
So we can talk about
that the Hilbert space
that this thing lives in.
So we can think about particle
1 with angular momentum J1.
And this is basically
spanned by the states
J1, M1 of these [INAUDIBLE].
We can take another
system with another J2,
and this is going to have
states J2, M2, with M2-- that
should be J1's there.
And that would similarly
talk about some Hilbert space
of some fixed angular momentum.
If we want to talk about
the electron in a hydrogen
atom, where it doesn't have a
fixed angular momentum, what we
really want to talk about
is the Hilbert space H1,
which is the sum over J1
of these Hilbert spaces.
And so this is talking
about-- this Hilbert space
contains every
state the electron
can have in a hydrogen atom.
It can have all the
different angular momenta.
And similarly we
could do that for J2.
We can define J, which is J1
plus J2, as you might guess.
And really this you should
think of as J1 tensor
the identity plus the identity
tensor J2, where this one is
acting on things in
this Hilbert space,
and the 1 here is acting on
things in this Hilbert space.
And similarly there's
an H2, J2 that
goes along with these guys.
And so this
operator, this big J,
is something that
acts on vectors
in things in this
tensor product space.
Actually I should
label this with a J1.
It also acts on things
in the full space,
but we can talk
just about that one.
So now we might
want to construct
a basis for this space.
And we conversely construct
an uncoupled basis
which is just take the basis
elements of each of the spaces
and multiply them.
So we would have J1, J2, M1, M2.
We'd have the states here.
And if we just ask
what our various--
J1 just gives us h bar
squared J, J plus 1.
And this one gives us h bar M1
h bar squared times our state.
And so we can think
about all of these.
And this is what we
label our state with.
And that's because these
form a complete set
of commuting observables.
And we'll just call
this the A set.
We can also talk
about our operator J
and use that to
define our basis.
And let's just be
a little explicit
about what J squared
is going to be.
So this is J1 tensor
identity plus 1 tensor J2.
And the same thing here.
If you expand this out you
get J1 squared tensor identity
plus 1 tensor J2 squared
plus the dot product, which
we can write as the
sum of J1k tensor J2k.
And because of this
piece here, J squared
doesn't commute with
J1z, for example.
So we can't add this
operator to our list
of operators over there.
And similarly J2z J
squared is not equal to 0.
So if we want to talk
about this operator
we have to throw
both of those away.
But there is an operator
total Jz that commutes with J
squared.
And it also commutes with
J1 squared and J2 squared.
And so we can have
another complete set
of commuting
observables B that's
equal to J1 squared, J2
squared, J squared, and Jz.
And so if there are observables
then the natural basis
is to label them by
the eigenvalues here.
So we're going to have a
J1, a J2, then a J and an M.
And so this is
the coupled basis.
Now both of these
bases are equally good.
They both span the full space.
They're both
orthogonal, orthonormal.
And so we can actually
write one basis
into in terms of the other one.
And that's the generic
problem that we
are trying to do
when we're trying
to write what we did
over here before,
when we did spin
1/2 cross spin 1/2.
We're trying to write
those products states
in terms of the coupled basis.
Well, they're both
orthonormal basis.
So I can expand J1, J2.
Well actually, maybe I'll
say one more thing first.
So being orthonormal means that,
for example, sum over J1, J2--
This is 1, right?
You can resolve the identity
in terms of these states.
And this is the identity
on this Hilbert space.
I can also think about
the identity just
on this smaller Hilbert space,
where the J1 and J2 are fixed.
And so I can actually write
it's the identity operator.
So because every
state in this space
has J1 equal to some fixed
value and J2 equal to some fixed
value, then an
identity in that thing
is just somewhere over the M's,
because they're the only things
there.
So using this, because I
know that the state J1, J2,
Jm has some fixed
value of J1 and J2,
I can write this as a sum.
I can use this form
of the identity.
So I've written my coupled basis
in terms of the uncoupled basis
here.
And these are just coefficients.
These are called
Clebsch-Gordan coefficients.
They're just numbers like square
root 2 and things like this.
And I tell you how to
do this decomposition.
So they have various properties.
Firstly, sometimes
you also see them
written as C of
J1J2J colon M1M2M
and various other notations.
So basically things
with six indices
are probably going
to be these guys.
So they have various properties.
The first property
is they vanish
if M is not equal to M1 plus M2.
And this is actually
very easy to prove.
So remember that Jz is just
going to be J1z plus J2z.
So as an operator I can
write Jz minus J1z minus J2z.
And what is that operator?
It's just 0, right?
This is equal to that.
So this is 0.
So I can put this 0 anywhere
I want and I'll still get 0.
So let's put this between--
so this is 0-- put it
between J1, J2, Jm on this side.
So a coupled state here.
And on this side I'll put it
between the uncoupled state,
J1, J2, M1, M2.
So this state is an
eigenstate of Jz.
And this state is an
eigenstate of J1z and J2z.
So I can act to
the right with Jz,
and act to the left
with these J1z and J2z,
and they have mission operators.
And I know because this is
0, this whole thing is 0.
So then act this
one on these guys
and these two back this way.
And so you see that
gives me h bar.
And then I get this
one acting on here
gives me M. And J1 acting
on here gives me M1.
And if M is not equal to M1
plus M2, then this term isn't 0.
But the whole thing is
so that has to be 0.
So that's QED.
The second property is that--
So they only allow values of J
fall in this range here.
And each J occurs once.
Now one way to
think about this is
to think of these
things as vectors.
So you have vector J1, and
then from the point of this
you can have vector J2.
But it can go into an
arbitrary direction.
So it can go up here,
or it can go like this.
These are meant to
be the same length.
And I can come all
the way down here.
But I can could only
sit on integer points.
And so this is kind of J2.
And so the length of this thing
here would be the length of J1
plus the length of J2.
So it would be this.
And then the length of up
to here would be this one.
And then all of the other
ones are in between.
But you can also just
look at the multiplicities
of the different states.
So if we look at the
uncoupled basis--
so the first state,
which was J equals J1,
there are two J1 plus
1 states, because it
can have all of the M values
from J1 down to minus J1.
And the other one can
have two J2 plus 1 states.
So that's the total number of
states that I expect to have.
So now let's assume
this is correct
and ask what the N coupled is.
So this would be the sum over
J equals mod J1 minus J2 up
to J1 plus J2 of 2J plus 1.
And let's assume that J1 is
greater than or equal to J2,
just to stop writing
absolute values all the time.
So we can write this as
the difference of two sums,
J equals 0 to J1 of--
J1 plus J2-- of 2J
plus 1 minus the
sum of J equals 0
to J equals J1 minus J2
minus 1 of 2J plus 1.
And if you go through-- so
this is just N,N plus 1 over 2
for each of these things.
You end up with, well,
you end up with this.
You end up with the same thing.
And so this is at
least consistent
that the number of
states that we have
is consistent with
choosing this.
One other thing we can do
is look at the top state,
and just see if that works.
See if that has the
right properties.
So because we know that the
J1, J2, J equals J1 plus J2,
M equals J1 plus J2.
So the maximal state, the
only way we can make this
is to take J1, J2, M1
equals J1, M2 equals J2.
Our spins are completely aligned
in the total up direction.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Sir, would you be
able to write a little larger?
PROFESSOR: Yes, sorry.
OK, yeah.
That's why I like a big chalk.
But we've run out of
big chalk, so I'll try.
So we know, also,
that J squared is
equal to J1 squared plus J2
squared plus the dot product.
We can write that out as
J1 squared plus J2 squared
plus 2J1z J2z plus J1 plus J2
minus plus J1 minus J2 plus.
And then we can ask what does
J squared on this state give?
And this is J1, J2, J1
plus J2, J1 plus J2.
So J squared, so we know
what that should be.
That should return J1 plus J2
times J1 plus J2 plus 1 times
h bar squared, because J
is the good quantum number.
But let's let it
act on this piece.
So this equals J1
squared plus J2
squared plus 2J1z J2z plus J1
plus J2 minus plus J1 minus J2
plus acting on J1, J2, J1, J2.
So this state here.
So we know how that acts.
So this one gives
us-- everything
gives us an h bar squared.
This gives us J1 J1
plus 1, for this term,
plus J2 J2 plus 1
for the second term.
Each of these gives us
the M quantum numbers.
But that's J1 J2.
So this is plus 2J1, J2.
And now what does this one do?
J1 plus on this state.
AUDIENCE: Kills it.
PROFESSOR: Kills it, right.
Because it's trying to
raise the M component of 1,
and it's already maximal.
And this one, J2
plus, also kills it.
So you get plus 0 plus
0 times the state.
So if you rearrange all
of this you actually
find you can write
this as J1 plus J2, J1
plus J2 plus 1 times the
state, which is what you want.
So the J squared operator acting
in the coupled basis gives--
well, acting in
the uncoupled basis
gives you what you expect
in the coupled basis.
So now I need a big blackboard.
So let's do an example of
multiplying two things.
So let's write out a multiplet.
So we're going to
take J1, and we're
going to have J1
bigger than J2 here.
So we've got J1
J1, J1 J1 minus 1.
And then somewhere down here
I've got J1 and 2J2 minus J1.
And then all the way
down to J1 minus J1.
So this has two
J1 plus 1 states.
And I'm going to tensor
that was another multiplet,
with my J2 multiplet, which
is going to be smaller.
So I'm going to have J2 J2.
Oh, maybe I'll put one more in.
And down here we've
got J2 comma minus J2.
And so here we have
two J2 plus 1 states.
And importantly,
this left hand side
has two J1 minus J2 more states
than the right hand side.
Just counting those states
that's pretty obvious.
So now let's start
multiplying these things,
and forming states of particular
values of M, the total M.
So if we say we want M equals
J1 plus J2 what can we do?
How can we make that?
So we have to take the
top state in each case.
Because if I take this one
and I take this M value,
I can't get up to this, right?
So there's only one
way to make this.
So I'm going to draw
a diagram of this.
We're going to have
a one state there.
The next M value, J1 plus J2
minus 1, how can I make that?
So I can start with
this state, and I
will multiply it
by this one, right?
Or, what else can I do?
AUDIENCE: Start
with the second down
on the left and
tensor with the top?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So I take those two.
So there are two states.
And those two states are
just two linear combinations.
So let me draw two dots
here, I can form two states.
Keep going-- minus 2,
I get three states.
And let me try and draw lines
here to guide this stuff.
OK, I'm not going to keep going.
But at some point
we get-- what's
the largest number of
states of a given M
I can make going to be?
Can anyone see that?
AUDIENCE: 2J2 plus 1?
PROFESSOR: 2J2 plus
2, right, because I've
got 2J2 plus 1 states here.
And I'm taking one of
these plus one of these
will give me-- so down here I'll
have an M equals-- what is it--
J1 minus J2.
And here I have
2J2 plus 1 states.
And so let me kind of draw
some of these states in.
And then dot, dot, dot.
And then over here we
end up with this guy.
So if I go down to the
next one, how many states?
So to form those states I
was taking this top state
with the bottom state here.
That gives me J1
minus J2, right?
Or I was taking the second state
here with the second to bottom
state here, and so forth.
And then all the way up to here.
Now if I then start shifting
things down in this side,
but leave exactly the
same things over there,
then I'll lower J by 1.
And I'll keep doing it
until I hit the bottom.
And because there's
this number of states
more in the right hand side than
the left hand side-- hang on,
let me just write this one.
OK, we might need to
go onto the next board.
So this keeps on
going until I get
to M equals-- I don't
remember the number-- M
equals J2 minus J1.
And there are 2J plus 2
plus 1 states of this.
And then once I do
that, then I start
having fewer and fewer states.
Because I've gone
basically moving out
the bottom of this multiplet.
And so here we have, this is
2 J1 minus J2 plus 1 rows.
And then I start contracting.
So the next one, M equals
J2 minus J1 minus 1
has two J2 states.
So then we can keep going.
And this is meant to continue
this diagram up here.
So then we keep going
down, down, down.
And then we'd have M
equals minus J1 plus 1.
And how many states can
I make that have that?
So I need to take this one,
and I could take the-- oh,
where is it?
Sorry, not this.
This is not what I mean.
Minus J1 minus J2 plus 1.
That's more obvious, right?
So there's two states.
And so this picture
has kind of-- this line
starts coming in.
And now I've got
my two states here.
I have the next one,
I've got three states.
And then finally, M equals minus
J1 minus J2, I have one state.
And so I get this.
And so you actually-- oh,
that was not very well drawn.
So if you look how many states
there are in this first column,
how many is going to be there?
So it goes from plus J1 plus
J2 to minus J1 minus J2.
So there's two J1 plus
J2 plus 1 states there.
And here there is two
J1 plus J2 minus 1
plus 1 states in this guy.
And so this is a J
equals J1 plus J2.
This one is J equals
J1 plus J2 minus 1.
And if you are careful you'd
find that this one here,
the last one here, this
has this many states in it,
two J minus 1 plus 1 states.
So this is a J
equals J1 minus J2.
And to be completely
correct, we put
an absolute value in case
J2 is bigger than J1.
So this is our full multiplet
structure of this system.
So all of the states
in this column
will transform into each
other under rotations,
and things like this.
And same for each column, they
all form separate multiplets.
So just some last
things before we finish.
So another property
of Clebsch-Gordan
coefficients we can
choose them to be real.
They satisfy a
recursion relation
but don't have a
nice, closed form.
I think this is in Griffiths.
It gives you what this
recursion relation is.
I think it does, at
least many books do.
And also, they're tabulated
in lots of places.
So if you need to
know the values,
you can just go
and look them up,
rather than trying to
calculate them all necessarily.
And I think that's all
we've got time for.
So are there any
questions about that?
Any questions about
anything else?
OK, great.
So we will see you on
Wednesday for the last lecture.